et voilà l'installation en direct
bonjour Bruno bretagneau merci beaucoup
d'être invité politique ce matin
sénateur de la Vendée président du
groupe les républicains et candidat à la
présidence des républicains on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien les Cuillier de
la Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
monsieur on a beaucoup de sujets à voir
avec vous avec tellement parler des
réformes de votre candidature à la
présidence des républicains mais d'abord
Eric Dupont-Moretti Eric Dupont-Moretti
est renvoyé devant la Cour de Justice de
la République c'est une situation
inédite est-ce que pour vous il peut
rester en poste
ce qui me choque en réalité ça dépend de
la doctrine du chef de l'État mais quand
on a une doctrine on s'y tient ce qui me
choque c'est le de poids et mesures
c'est le fait du prince c'est-à-dire que
Monsieur Beyrou qui était dans une
situation comparable puisqu'il était
garde des Sceaux a dû partir et que
Monsieur Dupont-Moretti reste ce qui me
choque aussi c'est que Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti va être amené à désigner
le procureur général près la Cour la
prestation c'est à dire qu'il devra
désigner nommer celui qui le jugera
c'est compliqué d'être jugé parti donc
on a des circonstances qui sont pesantes
et une fois de plus je veux dénoncer le
fait du prince c'est à dire que même
Macron a une forme à géométrie variable
de doctrine en fonction des selon vous
il doit se mettre en retrait de ses
fonctions jamais la démission de qui
conclut
mais très franchement là il y a un vrai
problème institutionnel à partir je suis
pas dupe non plus je crois qu'il y a
aussi une question de réglement de
compte entre lui ancien avocat et les
juges voilà donc c'est pour ça que j'y
vais la mettre en vente mais ce que je
dénonce c'est une situation qui est une
situation
ubuesque ou encore une fois celui qui va
bientôt être jugé par la Cour de Justice
de la République va être amené à
contribuer à la nomination de son juge
est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur la juris
qui dit qu'un ministre mais en examen
doit quitter le gouvernement ce que je
pense moi c'est ce que je vous indiquais
c'est que quand se tiennent quand il y a
un cap on s'y tient moi je n'étais pas
pour la jurisprudence baladure mais il a
commencé aussi avec cette jurisprudence
voilà ça peut pas être du de poids de
mesure en permanence on peut pas avoir
l'indignation à géométrie variable c'est
ce fait du prince c'est-à-dire que un
jour on choisit un cap et on en change
le lendemain c'est 6 caractéristiques en
réalité du comportement du chef de
l'État c'est à dire qu'il ne se tient à
aucune ligne parce que il semble tenir à
rien du tout il y a un relativisme qui
est préoccupant je trouve quand on est à
la tête de l'État il y a besoin quand
même une forme de Constance d'une forme
de cohérence on va parler des réformes
oui et elles sont nombreuses à arriver
dans la au Parlement en fin de en fin
d'année des mesures qui devraient
trouver a priori votre approbation je
pense à l'assurance chômage à la réforme
des retraites ce que vous vautrez ces
textes
on votera pas les textes sans les
amender ce que je veux dire c'est que on
a une ligue moi je me suis engagé dans
la campagne pour la présidence de LR
pour relever une droite quatre trop
souvent renoncés reculés et qui a
pratiqué parfois s'il zigzag voilà donc
moi je pense que la politique sont les
convictions et on doit l'appliquer ce
principe de tenir à ses convictions doit
l'appliquer aussi sur les textes
qu'est-ce que je veux dire ça n'est pas
parce que si demain email Macron nous
propose de reculer l'âge légal de départ
qu'on va voter contre parce que c'est
Monsieur Macron qui va nous proposer
c'est une girouette lui puisque il y a 5
ans il avait dit surtout pas faut rester
à 62 ans on a d'ailleurs vu la
conséquence la conséquence ça a été
l'appauvrissement de 8 millions de
retraités avec la CSG et puis maintenant
l'inflation donc quand on me réforme pas
on voit bien que la preuve est faite que
quand on réforme pas on appauvrit les
Français donc oui si ça va dans le bon
sens nous ne voterons parce que on
considère que cette réforme de retraite
est un des piliers de la sécurité
sociale de notre modèle social
le bon sens c'est quoi pour vous c'est
forcément un report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite où il y a un
compromis c'est un allongement de la
durée de cotisation pour votre point
d'équilibre nous l'avons déjà trouvé
puisque chaque année on dépose dans le
cadre du projet de budget de la Sécurité
sociale un amendement que dit cet
amendement il joue en fait sur les deux
paramètres sur les deux leviers on passe
de 62 à 64 ans et aussi on accélère la
réforme Touraine qui jouait elle sur la
durée de cotisation pourquoi est-ce que
l'on fait ça il faut le dire aux
Français nous on veut protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités qui a été
très atteint ces dernières années
première chose on pense que le système
para répartition est une bonne chose
mais c'est aussi l'équilibre entre les
jeunes et les moins jeunes or notre
natalité est en train de s'effondrer
donc il faut pas mettre sur le dos de
nos jeunes générations un poids
insupportable et puis on veut des
nouveaux droits vous voyez c'est ça la
droite la droite c'est de dire aux
Français on peut pas raser raciste il
faut plus de travail on travaille un peu
plus mais collectivement c'est pour
améliorer le sort de chacun et des plus
faibles ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
n'est pas normal d'avoir des retraites
aujourd'hui à 800 euros quand on a
travaillé dur et certainement Emmanuel
Macron et bien sûr mais rouge qui fait
que vous ne voterez pas cette réforme
puisqu'on la connaît pas exactement à
l'heure actuelle plateforme c'est pour
ça que je peux pas vous donner de lignes
de rôle si la ligne rouge pour moi ce
serait une fausse réforme des retraites
voilà donc on verra le cycle
il y a trois je pense qu'il faut
nécessairement le report de l'âge légal
et est-ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui
c'est que pour ceux qui disent le report
de l'âge légal c'est injuste vis-à-vis
des longues carrières bien sûr mais il y
a un dispositif aujourd'hui sur les
longues carrières ce dispositif il a été
voté en 2010 quel est ce dispositif
quand vous avez quatre trimestres de
cotisation avant la fin de votre 20e
année et que vous avez 43 ans d'annuité
vous pouvez partir à 60 ans donc ce sont
des mécanismes type longue carrière type
pénibilité qu'il faudra aussi garder
juste un dernier mot sur cette réforme
de retraite puisque le gouvernement dit
que cette réforme ne va pas seulement
servir à financer le système d'air
retraite mais va aussi servir à financer
l'éducation la transition écologique ça
c'est un problème pour vous je pense en
tout cas que partie en donnant ses
arguments là c'est être quasiment sûr
d'encourager le blocage et les
crispations je pense que la retraite
d'ailleurs le chef de l'État l'avait dit
un jour c'est la mère des réformes c'est
la mère des réformes parce que ça
consiste à dire aux Français on peut
collectivement améliorer et surtout la
soustabilité de notre système social
mais à condition de mettre plus de
travail dans notre économie il y a pas
assez de travail dans notre économie en
France et pour ça que les Français ça
pourrissent première chose et c'est
aussi une question budgétaire puisque
c'est un modèle qui ne sera pas
soutenable si jamais on ne fait pas
cette réforme par le travail les
retraites de nos aînés baisseront et
d'ailleurs la preuve en a été faite
quand et Macron a dit on stoppe on à 62
ans et bien dans le quinquennat dernier
jamais les retraités ont autant perdu de
pouvoir d'achat oui autre actualité
aujourd'hui doivent être dévoilées les
mesures de plein de sobriété du
énergétique du gouvernement alors il y
en a quelques-unes qui ont déjà été
dévoilées un bonus pour les nouveaux
covoiturageurs eau chaude coupé dans les
administrations éclairage réduits dans
les dans les stades qu'est-ce que vous
en retenez et surtout est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on va dans le bon sens il faut
de la sobriété c'est fondamental mais on
est trop dans la communication
la sobriété ça peut pas être simplement
le col roulé ou Tancarville voilà moi
j'ai fait des propositions pour dire que
on pouvait obtenir une sobriété grâce
aux nouvelles technologies je vais être
très concret il y a 20 ans
vous aviez des mécanismes qui vous
permettaient d'être très sobre et en
économisait en effacement pas des
grandes industries mais surtout des
particuliers 6 gigawatts 20 ans après ça
a été divisé par 10 que s'est-il passé
tout simplement parce que on a eu des
mécanismes qui ont vieilli et qui ne
produisent plus de cebrité moi j'ai mis
sur la table une proposition on a 36
millions de compteurs intelligents Linky
il y a des boîtiers à condition que les
gens soient volontaires pas question que
enedis
subrepticement phase des coupures mais
beaucoup de Français si vous dites aux
Français il y aura quelques micros
effacements 10 minutes le matin 10
minutes l'après-midi et bien les petits
ruisseaux font les grandes rivières qui
font la mer et ça ça nous permettrait
d'économiser vous rendez compte
tenez-vous bien l'équivalent de 2 et
demi à trois EPR grâce à ça et surtout
vous rendriez du pouvoir d'achat aux
Français parce que on tarifierait le
kilowatt-heure effacé à l'heure de
pointe et ce kilowatt effacé et bien ça
serait bon puisque il y aurait pas
besoin de le produire en électricité
mais surtout on rembourserait aux
Français le tarif du kilowatt effacé
c'est ça la bonne direction qui faille
changer de culture je suis d'accord mais
une fois de plus le gouvernement est
dans la communication il est aussi dans
l'infantilisation je trouve des Français
on l'a vécu aussi pendant la crise covid
c'est une sorte de discours qui se tient
de haut surplombant les Français et une
forme de pédagogie qui dit aux Français
à écouter soyez capable de mieux faire
un petit peu comme un maître d'école
vis-à-vis de ses élèves je pense que il
y a une faiblesse et le gouvernement ce
que je lui demande moi suite une
stratégie et la sobriété très bien mais
n'oublions pas l'immense échec des mâles
Macron qui a sabordé la filière
nucléaire parce que le résultat c'est
quoi c'est que on a fermé Fessenheim
voilà y compris madame borne qui était
aux affaires au gouvernement dans ce
ministère à l'époque on a fermé
Fessenheim qui nous manque aujourd'hui
et on va ouvrir
volts qui fonctionnent au charbon et qui
va accélérer le réchauffement climatique
ça c'est la responsabilité du chef de
l'État quand on n'a pas de boussole eh
bien on présente un jour la facture aux
Français autre question qui touche à
l'énergie mais vous l'aurez noté les
tensions sont énormes dans les
stations-service et ça se multiplie
partout en France dans ma région des
Hauts-de-France il y a 30 % des stations
de service qui sont qui ne sont pas
approvisionnés
est-ce que l'État doit réagir rapidement
oui l'État doit réagir alors c'est pas
de la faute de l'état non plus enfin
juste d'où vient le problème c'est à la
fois le fait que Total ait fait une
ristourne donc bah les consommateurs
connaissent et savent lire le prix à la
pompe et ensuite il y a des grèves voilà
mais ces grèves durs et dur depuis trop
longtemps et il va arriver à un moment
donné où ça va ça peut bloquer
l'économie française donc évidemment que
le gouvernement doit s'emmêler doit s'en
mêler en étant arbitre justement pour
faire en sorte que piqué de grève soit
je l'ai parce que ça va atteindre
l'intérêt général là je pense que ça
c'est quelque chose qui est cette
question de l'énergie l'énergie est à
l'économie ce que la sève est un arbre
c'est un bien qui est un bien absolument
stratégique qui doit être souverain et
on a fait encore une fois beaucoup
l'Europe a fait aussi beaucoup d'erreurs
en dérégulant le marché dans les années
2000 ça n'est pas une marchandise comme
une autre c'est une marchandise
stratégique qu'on ne peut pas stocker
souveraine
erreur aussi quand l'Europe faisait
pression sur la France pour démanteler
EDF erreur sur la tarification et à ses
erreurs européennes malheureusement
c'est ajouté une faute française comme
je vous le disais François Hollande plus
Emmanuel Macron avec qui ont mis à bas
ce qui était notre flow quand même la
filière nucléaire
une petite question aussi sur le la loi
de programmation budgétaire le groupe LR
à l'Assemblée a voté contre cette loi de
programmation un test qui pourtant
devrait recevoir plutôt votre
bénédiction puisqu'il prévoit de ramener
le déficit à 3% du PIB d'ici 2027 une
stabilité des effectifs de la fonction
publique alors ce qui fait qu'on a un
petit peu du mal à comprendre la
position de la droite républicaine en ce
moment ah non mais c'est très très clair
et je dis que le groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale a eu raison c'est un texte de
programmation
qui expriment toute comment dirais-je la
faiblesse du gouvernement en matière de
finance publique et que je m'explique 1
nous sommes nous serons la France les
derniers à atteindre les 3% en 2027 de
déficit budgétaire de en fait dans ces
hypothèses ces hypothèses ont
sous-estimé des dépenses et on
surestimer des recettes donc c'est un
faux semblant une fois de plus 3
regardez le budget on augmente de
pratiquement 11000 nombre de
fonctionnaires si suffisait d'augmenter
toujours plus le nombre de
fonctionnaires pour qu'un pays aille
bien pour qu'on ait des bons services
publics croyez-moi la France encore une
fois on serait à l'avant-garde du
bonheur universel comme j'ai la buté de
le dire donc il y a plein d'hypothèses
qui sont des hypothèses qui sont
totalement biaisés et ce comment
dirais-je cet exercice c'est un exercice
de style mais en aucun cas il porte une
forme de vérité des chiffres d'ailleurs
d'autres que moi le le comité de nos
conseils aussi des finances publiques
donc la Cour des comptes a indiqué la
faiblesse de toutes ces hypothèses donc
voilà on a eu raison de ne pas voter et
nous ne le voterons pas parce qu'il va
revenir au Sénat je pense il reviendra
au Sénat il est pas question de voter ce
texte qu'est-ce qu'il a été présenté
parce qu'il est mauvais pour l'économie
française malheureusement on n'est pas
sorti du quoiqu'il en coûte
malheureusement un mot sur le budget
parce qu'il y a un débat au sein de la
majorité sur le plafonnement des droits
de succession à robergé voulait déposer
un amendement ça divise sa majorité que
les LR vont déposer un amendement aussi
dans ce sens bien sûr je vous parlais de
la politique des convictions moi je veux
une politique des convictions on a fait
campagne à la présidentielle pour faire
en sorte que en matière de droite en
tout cas les donations la fiscalité sur
les taux nationaux la fiscalité sur les
successions on puisse les alléger voilà
donc on n'a pas changé de pieds en
quelques mois donc vous allez déposer
bien sûr sur les collectivités puisque
là aussi on parle budget énergie les
collectivités à payer la facture des
hausses des prix d'énergie est-ce que
vous allez défendre là aussi un
amendement qui indexe la dotation
globale de fonctionnement sur
l'inflation ce que demande des élèves il
y a plusieurs façons de le faire il y a
plusieurs voix de le faire déjà nous il
y a un problème c'est que on a voté
430 millions d'euros dans le projet de
loi de finances rectificative c'était en
juillet et aucune des communes de France
n'a vu la moindre goutte d'eau arrosé le
sable ses finances publiques aucune donc
on veut savoir exactement ce qu'il en
sera mais on ne peut pas laisser les
collectivités dans un état pareil ce qui
est incroyable vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques là encore il y a une
faiblesse vous savez que en 2027 le taux
d'endettement ce sera 110%. c'est énorme
sauf que qu'est-ce qui contribue au tout
petit des endettement à moins de 1% près
c'est pas l'état l'état passera de 92 %
à 99 non c'est la sécurité sociale et
c'est les collectivités donc une fois de
plus et c'est un autre argument que
j'ajoute une fois de plus l'état contre
sur les collectivités locales je vous
rappelle que elle représente 9% moins de
10% de l'endettement français que
lorsque elles investissent elles peuvent
pas le faire elles peuvent pas emprunter
par exemple pour financer leur personnel
leur fonctionnement ce que fait
aujourd'hui l'État il y a une gestion
qui est vertueuse donc non on ne
laissera pas tomber les collectivités
tout simplement parce que c'est elle qui
pour 70% contribue à l'investissement
public en France la semaine prochaine le
Sénat va examiner la loi locmin votre
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui donne plus de moyens aux
forces de l'ordre les les républicains
veulent sanctionner plus durement les
violences envers les élus les refus
d'obtempérer les rôdes urbains est-ce
que ça conditionne pour vous le vote de
ce texte très clairement nous on veut
sortir de cette habitude d'Emmanuel
Macron qui réduit sa politique à la
dépense publique il pense que toute
problème peut être réglé avec toujours
plus d'argent public c'est en réalité le
quoi qu'il en coûte et nous et on a
montré dans beaucoup de domaines que
plus on ajoute d'argent public c'est pas
pour ça que on va traiter les causes
nous on veut traiter les causes donc on
ne veut pas une loi une loop me qui ne
serait qu'une loi de moyen bien sûr il
faut des moyens pour les gendarmes pour
les policiers mais il faut aussi traiter
à la racine la cause de l'insécurité
c'est pour ça que on a fait des
propositions pour une réponse pénale
beaucoup plus forte en matière de rodéo
urbain en matière de violence faite aux
élus vous savez que les violences faites
aux élus en un an ont augmenté de 57%.
donc on veut les aligner pour les
sanctions
la même chose quand vous agressez un élu
par exemple un maire même chose que si
vous adressiez un policier ou un
gendarme et ça pour nous c'est
fondamental
juste précision parce que Gérald
Darmanin est venu à Nantes justement
pour parler des problèmes d'un
insécurité très important que connaît
que connaît la ville il a aussi annoncé
un renforcement des moyens c'est plutôt
une satisfaction pour vous c'est une
politique de communication ah oui je
suis allé vendredi dernier je suis allé
parce que Nantes j'ai fait une partie de
mes études à Nantes c'est une ville qui
tous les ans jadis remportait le
palmarès des villes où il fait le mieux
bon vivre ben voilà et aujourd'hui c'est
devenu un coupe-gorge non je suis allé
au commissariat vous savez ce qu'ils
m'ont dit les policiers ils m'ont dit
écoutez rien ne change bien sûr qu'ils
veulent des moyens évidemment ils m'ont
dit rien ne changera si on ne met pas
fin 1 au laxisme pénal il faut une
révolution pénale alors que le garde des
sceaux vient de signer le 20 septembre
dernier une circulaire que dit cette
circulaire et dit même quand elle la
presse au parquetier au procureur de la
République de France cette circulaire
dit même pour les multirécidivistes il
faut toujours préférer à la prison l'été
IG les travaux d'intérêt général penser
que ça va aller y soit la fin de ce
laxisme construire des prisons des
peines d'emprisonnement certaines parce
que c'est la meilleure des dissuasion et
deux le laxisme migratoire ils m'ont
révélé un chiffre stupéfiant ils m'ont
dit que les mises en cause pour des
faits de délinquance sur la voie
publique dans le grand centre-ville de
Nantes de 60 à 70% c'était le fait c'est
les mises en cause là d'immigrants vous
pensez qu'on peut rester comme ça vous
pensez que on peut rester avec des
frontières qui sont des vrais passoires
tant qu'on te mettra pas fin au laxisme
pénal au laxisme migratoire la France
sans sauvagera
oui et une réponse simplement à cette ce
début de polémique qui s'est qui s'est
construit autour de la de l'envoi par
Aurélien Pradier d'une lettre à des
dizaines de milliers d'adhérents de des
républicains alors Aurélien Pradier qui
est votre concurrent à la présidence de
la de des républicains qui aurait
utilisé un fichier des adhérents alors
qu'en théorie les candidats au Congrès
n'ont pas l'utiliser ce que ça vous
choque et ce que vous réclamez des
explications j'écris moi aussi bien à la
Présidente j'ai écrit aussi à la Haute
autorité pour que l'ensemble des
candidats connaissent des conditions
équitables Aurélien Pradier et
secrétaire général donc j'imagine qu'il
peut avoir accès à un certain nombre de
choses moi je n'y ai pas accès donc il
fréquent
il est président de la CNI en tout cas
moi ce que je constate c'est que
évidemment qu'il y a des mails qui a
donc des fichiers qui sont utilisés je
pense qu'il faut que cette élection ne
souffre aucune contestation et il faut
évidemment assurer une équité de
traitement tout le monde c'est tout
voilà vous vous craignez que ça soit pas
le cas à l'heure actuelle je veux
vraiment que ça soit vous en doutez je
pense qu'il y a quelques marges de
progression
le temps de la campagne Aurélien Pradier
devrait se mettre en retrait vous pensez
de ces fonctions de secrétaires
générales écoute ça écoutez moi c'est
pas mon affaire je veux en tout cas que
il y a un fair-play voilà on sport mais
aussi dans une compétition pas seulement
sportive mais électorale c'est normal
que les compétiteurs puissent avoir les
mêmes conditions je veux dire pour faire
campagne même accès à tous ces
informations qui sont importantes c'est
tout moi je pense que il faut faire
attention parce qu'on sait très bien que
tes campagnes internes parfois ça peut
être très dur on doit pas être la droite
la plus bête du monde on est compétiteur
mais on n'est pas des adversaires voilà
mais il faut aussi préserver je veux
dire se faire plaire c'est c'est équité
dans cette compétition électorale
d'adhérents aussi qui sont faites
j'avais demandé il y a quelques mois
qu'on tire les conséquences
de la campagne précédente et j'avais
demandé à ce que la Haute Autorité
puisse faire un certain nombre de
sondages quand par exemple il y a des
patronymes différents qui sont rattachés
au même domicile ou qui est des noms
différents rattachés au même numéro de
téléphone ça c'était préventif pour
essayer
non non je veux simplement m'assurer que
justement que l'élection soit
incontestable croyez moi j'ai vécu moi à
l'époque la guerre enfin la guerre qui
n'est pas une guerre mais les problèmes
entre Jean-François Copé François Fillon
il y a quelques années il est absolument
pas question de revenir à ce genre de
choses donc voilà tirons-en les leçons
quand même on n'est pas non plus la
droite la plus bête du monde très bien
alors tire 11 ans les leçons et essayons
d'appliquer des règles qui soient des
règles normales c'est tout
par beaucoup d'élus Bruno matériaux
beaucoup d'élus locaux beaucoup de
parlementaires est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas d'être plus le candidat des
élus que des militants qui votent
d'abord que des élus me soutiennent qui
soient parlementaires qui est des maires
c'est bien parce que ils ont des nombres
réseaux et puis parce que s'ils ont été
élu c'est parce que ils ont été capables
d'affronter justement le suffrage
universel et moi j'ai un immense respect
pour les élus qui se dévouent énormément
c'est difficile je croyais moi
aujourd'hui d'être élu mais je me
déplace beaucoup et ce qui me surprend
dans le Nord on s'est croisé puisque on
était j'étais à Lambersart il y a
quelques semaines là ça allait était
pleine ils ont même rajouté vous pouvez
en témoigner quelques chaises donc vous
voyez bien que non non les salles sont
des belles salles et ça suscite un
intérêt et je pense que voilà nos
applaudissements aux questions que j'ai
je pense que ma candidature suscite
aussi un intérêt chez les militants
croyez moi intérêt réaction est-ce que
vous avez eu des des commentaires par
rapport à votre sortie sur le fait que
vous ne retiendrez pas Nicolas Sarkozy
devait quitter les républicains on
touche comme ça la figure du Commandeur
non mais c'est lui qui essaie le
commandeur qui qui m'avait provoqué
puisque je vous rappelle que c'est parti
d'une indiscrétion dans un non pas dans
un quotidiens en disant non sirota yoyo
est élu je quitterai l'air donc voilà
quand on me cherche on me trouve
d'accord il m'a trouvé non non bien sûr
j'ai beaucoup de réactions j'ai beaucoup
de réactions qu'est-ce que c'est
terrible mais mais son attitude a
beaucoup déçu au moment de la
présidentielle parce que on attendait de
quelqu'un qui effectivement est une
forme de figure tutélaire de notre
famille politique qui s'engage et
beaucoup y ont vu une sorte de soutien
plus ou moins implicite même peut-être
presque explicite à la reconduction
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est un mauvais
président de la République et qui n'est
pas du tout dans notre famille politique
ça n'est pas président de droite
Emmanuel Macron vous n'êtes pas un
président de vous nommez monsieur
papendiaye à la tête de l'éducation
nationale vous n'êtes pas un président
de droite quand vous pensez que en
matière d'immigration dont je parlais il
y a quelques instants il vaut mieux
envoyer les immigrés dans le milieu
rural plutôt que de maîtriser nos
frontières ça c'est pas être un
président de droite vraiment pas quand
on pose la question de soutien ils nous
disent Bruno c'est le candidat du
Rassemblement est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a un risque de fractures
d'implosion de votre partie cyrxautier
en tout cas je pense qu'après trois
échecs au présidentiel c'est l'élection
de la dernière chance
ce que moi je peux proposer
c'est mon ADN c'est à la fois la
clarification d'une ligne politique sans
concession mais aussi sans outrance sans
excès la fermeté vous me connaissez une
transgis jamais sur mes convictions mais
aussi cette capacité à rassembler et ça
c'est l'essence même de la politique oui
il y a des risques de fracture et
franchement quand on fait moins de 5% à
l'élection présidentielle est-ce qu'on a
le droit de cliver est-ce qu'on a le
droit de se rétrécir non à ce moment-là
ce serait la disparition j'en veux pas
donc je crois que avec ma candidature
nos militants peuvent avoir à la fois la
fermeté dans la ligne des convictions
mais aussi cette capacité à rassembler
ce que je montre
au Sénat je préside un groupe avec des
sensibilités très différentes ce que
j'ai montré à la région quand j'étais
président de Région de département
cliquez sur Xavier Bertron a récemment
au lancement de son mouvement nous
France a dit qu'il fallait clarifier
l'ADN des des républicains et notamment
dire clairement NON à toute idée mortels
d'union de la droite et de l'extrême
droite vous le rejoignez sur cette
position moi je ne résoudrai jamais à ne
pas tendre la main à ses électeurs qu'on
a déçu par notre faute qui sont partis
et qui ont voté Marine Le Pen
ery Zemmour qui ont parfois voté
monsieur Macron ou qui se sont absolus
moi ce que je veux c'est non pas l'Union
des droites mais l'Union de la Droite je
veux l'Union de la Droite par les
électeurs pas parler des appareils pas
par les appareils mais l'Union de la
Droite ou plutôt des droites qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire Madame Le Pen refuse
toute union avec elle de toute façon et
monsieur Zemmour on a fait les frais
ou vous dissolvez vous vous soumettez
mais vous ne vous alliez pas voilà donc
je pense que si la droite est ferme sur
ses convictions alors
enfin on peut séduire nos électeurs et
ce que je veux c'est créer un grand
parti populaire patriote qui fait des
rats tous les électeurs de droit ça
c'est ma volonté une dernière question
internationale sur l'Arménie oui puisque
vous avez déposé une proposition de
résolution pour appeler à des sanctions
contre l'Azerbaïdjan vous estimez que la
France ne va pas suffisamment loin dans
sa réponse moi j'étais choqué quand
madame vanderlione est allé en
Azerbaïdjan pour conclure un accord
gazier je ne sais pas si vous avez vu
les images horribles de ces combattants
Arméniens qui ont été désarmés et qui
ont été abattus froidement par les
azéries il y a quelques jours c'est
désormais
l'Azerbaïdjan qui attaque sur son propre
sol l'Arménie l'Arménie quitte avec le
peuple juif est un peuple qui a connu le
génocide et qu'est-ce que l'on fait on
va aller conclure un accord gazier
c'est-à-dire que avec cet accord gazier
on va permettre à l'Azerbaïdjan l'Europe
permet à laser d'acheter des armes qui
ont va massacrer des Arméniens
à quoi ça sert de brandir des grandes
valeurs morales pour arrêter et sans
doute fallait-il le faire les
importations de gaz russe alors que par
derrière sous cape on a la position
inverse avec laserbaïdjan qui attaque le
sol qui agresse l'Arménie qui agresse
donc un État souverain tout comme la
Russie a agressé attaqué un autre État
souverain l'Ukraine c'est la raison pour
laquelle et voyez c'est transpartisans
puisque le groupe communiste socialiste
nos amis Hervé Marcel groupe centriste
longue ou signé et donc c'est le Sénat
qui une fois de plus et c'est l'honneur
du Sénat qui est une fois de plus dira
nous on dénonce on ne veut pas le la loi
du silence merci Bruno retaille merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité la Une
de La Voix du Nord on en a parlé
carburant toujours plus compliqué les
services de durer encore un petit peu
[Musique]